a movie that we watching the TV shows us
from 25 to about 60 images per second in
computer graphics these images will
refer to as frames a slow motion camera
can capture up to the order of thousands
of frames per second
providing breathtaking footages like
this one can quickly discover the beauty
of even the most ordinary mundane
moments of nature but if you think this
is slow motion then take a look at this
computer graphics researchers have been
working on a system that is able to
capture one trillion frames per second
how much is that exactly well it means
that if every single person who lives on
earth would be able to help us then
every single one of us would have to
take about 140 photographs in one second
and we would then need to add all of
these photographs up to obtain only one
second of footage what is all this good
for
well for example capturing light as an
electromagnetic wave as it hits and
travels along objects in space like the
wall that you see here
physicists used to say that there is a
really really short instance of time
when you stand in front of the mirror
you look at it and there is no mirror
image in it it is completely black
what is this wizardry and how is this
possible since Einstein we know that the
speed of light is finite it is not
instantaneous it takes time to travel
from the light source hit the mirror and
end up hitting your eye for you to see
your mirror reflection researchers at
MIT and the university of zaragoza have
captured this very moment take a look it
is an enlightening experience
the paper is available in the
description box and it's a really
enjoyable read a sizable portion of it
is understandable for everyone even
without mathematical knowledge all you
need is just a little imagination thanks
for watching and I'll see you next week